i went upstairs to the penthouse i was
informed by amber that she got in the
fight with johnny last night she threw
his personal property over the balcony
into the streets 9th and broadway
and when you say personal property what
are you referring to
his phone wallet
credit cards passports everything that's
in his wallet
did uh miss hurd say anything else to
you about this altercation
nothing except she
they were fighting
so what what did you do after miss heard
informed you that she'd thrown mr deff's
personal property off the balcony
formulated a plan with norm from the
office to use the find my phone app
hit the streets and
try to get lucky
did you end up finding mr depp's phone
yes i did in skid row
probably six miles from the house
and who had the who had the phone
a
homeless gentleman unhoused gentleman
i approached him about the phone
he was honest he returned it i gave him
a reward for it and what was the reward
420 dollars
chicken tacos chips apples fiji water
after finding mr depp's phone what did
you do
i returned to the penthouse showed the
phone to amber that i retrieved it i
left it in the sheet in the cp for the
evening security to return it to mr deb
so after figuring out uh things with the
phone what what happened next
what happened next is i walked amber to
the car we got everybody in the car
she's on her way to coachella i went
back to the penthouse to retrieve the
dogs and the luggage
were you also going to coachella with
miss heard
yes i was i was the transportation for
amber and her friends while she was at
coachella
and did you have any discussions with
miss heard on the way to coachella that
evening
we had a conversation pertaining to the
surprise she left in the boss's bed
prior to leaving the apartment and when
you refer to the surprise in the boss's
bed what are you referring to
the defecation
and what did miss heard say about the
defecation in mr duff's bed
a horrible practical jerk gone wrong
mr jenkins what observations did you
make about miss heard at coachella in
april 2016.
she had no worry she was there to whoop
it up it's her birthday she's with her
friends
and how often were you with her that
weekend
was with her every day she went to the
venue from the time that we interacted
with the wallet incident
the night before at the party all the
way until monday we returned
with the pets and the luggage
and did you uh observe anything about
miss heard's health that weekend
she got sick
do you know what's sick at the venue
second night do you know what cosmis
herd to be sick
she was eating the magic mushrooms and
drinking red wine on an empty stomach
and
how do you know that she drank red wine
and took magic mushrooms
i saw the room service and i went to
their room to collect them to take them
out that evening so is that something
excuse me is that something you
witnessed
i witnessed it